who thought this franchise would have
hit eight installments would it was
Point Break light when they were just
racing cars down the road it was nobody
I thought it was like a woman died here
we are eight movies later holy the
fate of the Furious so the fate is a
Furious is the eighth film in the Fast
and Furious franchise and this one looks
like Dom Toretto has gone rogue
he has gone against them yeah dude was
always big on family and then he runs
across Charlize Theron who's like oh
yeah you're gonna work for me and
somehow she has something on him so now
he's working for her doing heists for
her and his old crews like nah we can't
turn her back on Dom I need to find out
what's up now I got to take on the one
thing they are no match for Dom Toretto
a street racer from the original Fast &
Furious movie really is one of the
things I was look at these movies are
like what makes him a badass it was
racing cars I hear people doing that a
few blocks from my house like what are
they going to save the free world this
is not Vin Diesel from triple-a is Vin
Diesel from phasma period doesn't
because the movie commits to its
absurdity it knows it's absurd it knows
what it is
it's lives it up it delivers a pretty
fun movie for it somehow it works dude
we have like submarines versus cars
that's what we knows it's not Macbeth
it's not trying to be Macbeth at a point
they were like yeah all right so the
street racing thing that's going to get
tired it's going to get old and
apparently it is people don't care what
do we do right make it a heist movie why
would we stop there when we can make it
a ridiculous heist movie that's what I
can say this movie's fun the action in
this movie is fun it was not guns being
shot at cars or rockets being shot at
cars blowing cars of it over themselves
it's the rock beating the out of
dudes I mean that hits when the rock
it's going toe-to-toe with a group of
bibble these guys are getting hurt
they're getting hurt bad if something
really gratifying about a solid hit that
breaks bones delivered by Dwayne Johnson
not gonna lie to you when Scorpion King
came out I was like I don't know just
dudes gonna last forever
help years ago we proved us and he's a
solid action star he's going to be
around for a very long time here he is
just getting better and better at his
craft the entire time he's just hitting
dudes I imagine him
Shazaam and a lightning bullet and
everything I don't know what I just want
to see him his blackout him at this
point granted whenever anyone's like
well the movies just fun actually this
is fun what they mean is the movies also
cheesy its cheesy for sure like you'd be
going here like okay physics matter
they're gonna be pissed you're gonna
walk out while your son doesn't make any
sense because it doesn't make it like
the physics move you're at a control not
only is the action absurd with the plots
of surge like really if a couple people
just went to the proper authorities and
we're like hey there's a problem I just
you know there you go deal with it that
probably would have been that granted
that's the case in a lot of movies but I
think it's really apparent this one my
mind was blown when I realized there's
an organization or a person called
cypher and then I was like who cypher
and hacking and what I was waiting at a
point this movie to be like okay this is
going to be Metal Gear Solid tie-in this
is it it never happened I will say on an
emotional level this movie does
surprisingly deliver it is an emotional
time in the last Fast and Furious movie
with the whole Paul Walker goodbye thing
I thought they handled that brilliantly
it's different than that but there are a
couple times on an emotional level of
like this movie is trying and even
succeeding guys in the end fate of the
Furious is the rarity in which case the
eighth installment of a franchise to
still entertainment if you're a physics
nut you need the action car chases
submarine fight Humvee versus comfort
you need it all that makes sense it's
not going through but if you can enjoy
some of that James Bond absurdity enjoy
the fights enjoy the characters and
enjoy the new conflict in this franchise
among the characters you're looking to
walk out of this movie having a good
time in fact a very good time no alcohol
required alright guys so fate of the
Furious have you seen it what did you
think about it what's your favorite Fast
& Furious movie of all time thus far II
have a few to choose from whatever it is
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]